Now we move from the flight toward the landing.
For the landing, it's important that we've looked beforehand at what landing pattern we want to fly.
Is it a right-hand or a left-hand pattern?
And above all, it's important that we all follow the same rules.
Because in this phase of the flight we're no longer far from the ground.
That means we have no more time, or very little time, to react.
When we have 1000 metres above the ground, if someone doesn't do something the way they should,
we have relatively long to react and assess the situation.
When landing, everything happens a bit faster, simply because the ground is close.
So the principle has to be that we all stick to the landing pattern,
and so we can guarantee that we see what the other pilot, the one ahead, is doing.
The landing pattern looks like this: we decide on a left-hand or right-hand pattern
and then we come into the position circles, our altitude-loss circles,
where we bleed off our altitude.
To start a clean landing pattern, it's important that we circle in the same direction
in which we're going to do the landing pattern.
If we do a right-hand pattern, it's a right-hand circle.
If we do a left-hand pattern, it's a left-hand circle.
Then we go to an altitude — the landing pattern — that's healthy.
And that healthy altitude is something you learn to gauge after one, two, three landings.
I already have it under pretty good control.
By looking at the visual reference point each time, you notice,
ah, right now I'm still this high.
And as a rule, it's better to come in too high and still land properly
than too low, because altitude gives you time.
Low altitude causes stress.
When you fly off from the position circle into the downwind leg,
don't use visual cues like,
for example, I'm always at tree height or I'm always at this house-level height
when I fly the downwind leg.
That can vary, depending on the air mass you're in;
it doesn't have to be the same at all.
It also changes completely when there's wind in play.
That's why it's important to develop a feel here.
You'll dare to do it; everyone has after two, three, four flights.
Others need a little more.
But that's why you're with the instructor on the radio,
where I can give you nice instructions,
so that at first you do it a bit remote-controlled
and after a certain number of flights you can do it on your own.
Downwind, base, final.
If we notice on the downwind that we're clearly too high,
we can simply turn onto base
and we can also extend the base leg.
If we have space, we go far, far forward and make a curve.
If we're too short, we notice we're not always that much higher.
Then we can also shorten the whole thing, as shown here.
Or we can also repeat the base leg with S-turns several times.
And the S-turns always have to follow proper reference points.
And the good thing about these S-turns is that at any moment we can
leave the base leg and turn onto final, if we see it fits.
Then comes final.
Final should be straight.
We can of course make a slight correction
if the wind comes from a bit of an angle.
But ultimately the important thing is that we fly straight toward the landing point.
If we notice we're way too high, there are various options.
We can, for example, make ourselves big.
That is, the pilot below the wing creates a lot of drag.
And whether we sit compactly — then we glide well and have little drag.
Or we make ourselves big.
That means we sit up out of the harness,
make sure that our landing gear, namely the legs, are already ready.
And then we create a lot of drag and have a poor glide.
That means we can bleed off altitude efficiently.
And that's how we approach the landing point.
Another option would be to fly very gentle S-turns.
That's also allowed.
Or, when we get to it later, to land with little-ears.
We pull the little-ears, the paraglider simply becomes smaller,
has more sink.
And that way you also have a better chance
of landing on the spot.
At the briefing, by the way, it's a 30-metre circle
that you have to hit, inside the circle.
And then you've passed the landing nicely.
One more important thing: when you pull the little-ears,
you have to be aware that your arms are in such a position
that you can't steer much anymore.
You can steer with weight shift,
but your manoeuvrability is limited,
and you have to keep that in mind.
So better to land a bit further out
than do something rashly or under stress.
That usually doesn't end well.
Then there are also situations
where the landing turns out a bit different
than we'd thought.
For example, we've flown the landing pattern,
we looked at the windsock up front,
and it was always nicely showing
that we should really land final into the wind,
as we normally do.
Now, unfortunately, we suddenly have a tailwind,
because the wind has simply shifted.
That's no drama, it's important
that we follow through with the landing pattern,
because we decided on this pattern
and then we just land with a tailwind.
With a tailwind that means
we have more speed on final.
So we have to brake through more quickly,
more decisively,
than we're used to on a normal landing.
On a normal headwind landing
we can brake through relatively comfortably,
until below the seat and stay down there,
but with a tailwind landing we have to be a bit higher
and really brake down decisively,
so we build a momentum
in which the wing stands up
and at exactly that moment we're on the ground.
Even with a tailwind you can
make nice landings
that come down on your feet.
So a tailwind landing is no drama,
but rather a point
you can practice well.
Of course, we're not talking about 30 km/h tailwind,
but about 5 to 10 km/h of wind
that you could manage.
Now it can also happen
that we have to do a slope landing.
That can also be the case,
for example, if a landing site is closed.
We have no other option.
The slope landing — it's important
that we don't, if we have the slope here,
that we don't simply fly straight into the slope,
because then the slope's inclination
really wrecks the calculation
during the flare,
but rather we have to land parallel to the slope.
Then we can make exactly the same landing,
touch down parallel to the slope,
then it works just fine.
Now it can also happen
that we've missed the landing site
and might land in a parking lot,
where cars are standing.
Or we have a fence in the way
that we didn't see beforehand.
On the landing site, the farmer
put a few cows on the meadow
and set up a sturdy fence.
We just didn't see the fence
and we're flying full-speed at it.
Now you can say,
okay, now you can mess up too,
you can't avoid the collision,
but you can at least still bleed off energy.
You can also do that
simply by
right over the land
braking fully through.
So that the energy is gone,
because there's a difference
between flying into a fence at 30 km/h
or only at 5 km/h, or even 0 km/h.
Then we can actually land on the fence.
So during a collision,
remember to bleed off energy
and don't just stay up there
and scream, that doesn't help.
All that does is get people watching
and you'll have even more spectators
in this embarrassing situation.
Wrong done,
you can no longer reach the landing site
and on the way to the landing site
there are only trees.
Then a tree landing might be
the worst thing you can do,
before you go somewhere toward a cliff face
or somewhere even dumber to land.
A tree landing, if you have the option,
preferably pick the conifer.
It holds up nicely.
You can hang on well to the branches,
as you come down,
and so, important, fly into it nicely.
Here, too, bleed off energy
using the brakes
and protect your head with your arms
from those branches.
Important: there are
good documentaries on tree rescues.
The paraglider pilot
who flies into the trees
is usually quite safe,
because lots of lines get caught in there.
That also applies if you had a reserve deployment
over a forest.
There's a lot of fabric, lots of lines,
and they tangle in the branches.
There are very few cases
where the pilot has gone through the trees
all the way to the ground.
Usually you stay hanging up there,
and then you're basically safe.
Most of the accidents that result from that
happen because people, in the shock —
and it's clearly a shock most of the time,
it's an emergency situation —
want to free themselves
and then fall.
Because, for example, in steep terrain
they're sitting in a tree
and looking sideways toward the terrain,
they see it's only 2 metres.
And when you then unbuckle from the harness
and fall,
15 metres is absolutely devastating.
Important, when this happens,
first and foremost, stay calm.
Calm, calm, calm.
And then give yourself time
and say, okay,
now we have to analyse the situation.
The smartest thing, if you're
in a civilised area,
is to inform mountain rescue anyway,
to inform the Rega.
Pretty likely someone has seen
the crash and maybe even already reported it.
We're glad
that you know where you are,
whether you're okay,
and whether you need help.
And in my view help is needed
any time you notice
you're in a tree
and it's also higher than 1-2 metres.
Then mountain rescue will come
and they can help you with that too.
Even with retrieving the wing it's much easier
than risking a fall,
where, as I said before,
you can fall from a height.
So, inform people
about what's happening and
wait for help.
Sometimes patience is needed.
In our region we have
a very nice partner
with the Rega, who are very fast
and accordingly
the rescue can be initiated very quickly.
Another landing situation,
which hopefully never applies,
which is why it's marked this way here,
is the water landing.
A water landing has to be avoided,
because a standing body of water
can get very, very cold in winter
and you get tangled very quickly
in lines and so on
and that can make you incapable
of swimming.
It's even worse
in a river.
In the river it drifts,
it's pretty uncontrollable
whether you'll even get out.
There, if you have the option,
as early as possible,
when you see that you'll go into the water,
open the harness buckles,
so that you can fly away from the gear immediately.
But what's important: never jump
before you hit the water,
out of the harness.
Because in the shock moment,
in the adrenaline you're in,
you don't have a grip on
whether you're 5 metres above the water surface
and jumping or whether you're at 20 metres,
and that can again have very serious consequences
if you misjudged it.
So, a water landing,
basically avoid it,
which means, for me,
I don't go training any manoeuvres
over water, over a river,
unless it's in a supervised training,
such as a SIV course,
where a boat is always ready out there,
where you make precise use
of the water surfaces,
because the water surfaces are nice,
we have no obstacles.
But if I'm just going out for a flight,
then I avoid water surfaces,
I avoid rivers and I avoid lakes.
If the whole landing thing
didn't work out the way
you wanted,
or you see
that maybe you didn't quite do it
as nicely as you would have liked
and you got hurt doing it,
it's important
that you know how to take care of an injured person.
In paragliding we have
unfortunately a disadvantage,
that we're in the seated position,
meaning, when we
come down from above,
we're always in the seated position,
it goes pretty directly onto the spine.
That's why spinal injuries
are not uncommon in paragliding
and when we come up to an injured person,
it's just as important
that we know that too.
That means, basically we have to
first calm things down and then
you notice relatively quickly
how badly or where the pilot is injured.
Is he really hurt in the back
and is he breathing,
is everything still working,
the best is to leave him lying
and immediately, right away, inform the Rega,
so they come with a helicopter
and can transport him out.
When the helicopter comes,
you have to know it generates a lot of wind
as soon as it lands.
That means he has to gather the wing,
maybe with a quick fold,
pack everything up and weigh it down
with stones or branches,
so that nothing can fly away
and endanger the helicopter.
Injuries that
affect the back
are also important.
If the pilot wants to sit up
or wants something to drink,
it's a normal reaction,
prevent it.
He should stay lying,
don't move, as long as he's responsive,
and don't give him anything to drink either.
That's extremely important,
because we don't know whether he has internal injuries
or not.
Now we come to the topic of flying technique.
It's about
all of us knowing
what our wing can actually do,
or rather, what we can influence,
so that the wing
glides better
or sinks less.
It's quite simply
visible on this scale,
that when we say
we want, with a school wing,
to get our best glide,
i.e. we go from point A
to point B
as far as possible,
then our brake
should be in contact at about 5-15 cm
at the speed
you can read here.
If we want to stay in the air
as long as possible,
i.e. get the minimum sink,
and we're not going furthest,
but we're in the air longest in terms of time,
then we have to apply a bit more brake,
namely already 15-10 km/h,
a bit more than trim speed.
And if we go minimum speed,
i.e. what the paraglider
is just barely willing to fly,
before it heads toward a parachutal stall,
which we'll get to later,
we're applying quite a lot of brake,
we're going right down to the hips.
Important: the elbows still face nicely downward.
And then
we're at about 40 cm,
where we're flying in a relatively slow range.
We can also do the opposite,
namely accelerate.
If we accelerate with our foot,
as is the case for most,
we can step through,
then we get a lot of speed back,
because we're doing nothing else
than reducing our angle of attack,
and we get faster.
And so the wing also flies significantly faster.
Quite simply put, we use the accelerator
any time
we have a headwind.
So in calm air
best glide is naturally best.
If we have a tailwind,
a bit more brake is
best, for minimum sink.
If we have a headwind,
then we have to accelerate.
Quite simply put,
for understanding,
we fly 30 km/h,
we have 30 km/h headwind,
we'd be standing still.
Thank god we can accelerate,
if we can get another 10 km/h or so out of it
and then we do fly 10 km/h forward.
That would be the advantage,
to still reach the landing site
or wherever we're flying to.
So there's not only flying
as such with launch and landing,
as we've already discussed,
but it should also be fun.
There's also so-called soaring.
When we can use the ridge lift,
then we're really talking about soaring.
If it's a regional wind
blowing up the slope,
that generates a band of lift,
and in this band of lift
we can climb out high above the ridge,
and that's called soaring.
It's usually purely wind-driven.
There's also thermo-dynamic soaring,
which is somewhat mixed with thermals.
Here we're talking about soaring.
There it's important,
right from beginner level:
terrain clearance, terrain clearance
and again terrain clearance.
Why?
Because we're next to the terrain the whole time.
There may be other pilots in the air
who also want to fly there
and create a bit of turbulence
with their aircraft.
It can quickly get rough
or there can be a bit more wind
and it drifts us a bit more
toward the slope, so we have time
to react, so we fly away from the slope again.
And in general,
always turn the curve away from the slope.
Never toward the slope.
Here we have
tailwind components.
We have sink-rate components
from the turn itself.
It's not predictable.
And when you fly with a tailwind like that,
you also have to
always firmly observe the things listed here
when soaring.
Now, depending on the area,
we naturally also have thermal flying.
And thermal flying is what's
probably the supreme discipline
in paragliding.
We want to fly as far as possible.
That means we want to use thermals
as a transporter.
Because if we only fly in calm air,
then we have, given our glide ratio,
if we, for example, launch from 1000 metres,
then we'd reach 8 kilometres.
In calm air.
But now we have thermals.
That means I also have to
know how I
behave with thermals at all
and how I fly them.
Thermal flying. So that I can fly thermals,
I also need to know a few basic rules.
The easiest, of course,
is when we have visual confirmation
via a cloud — then we see
the thermal optically.
It's significantly easier to fly that way.
We'll now take the example of the cloud.
When we have wind, it's relatively easy
to find the column.
Then we simply fly straight under the cloud
and have found the column relatively quickly.
Hopefully we can climb.
The whole thing gets a bit harder when we have wind.
We'll take the example here
that the wind comes from the left.
So the cloud is drifted like that.
That means, with the wing I now have
to fly into the upwind side of the cloud,
so that I can climb nicely in the column
together with the wind drift
and optimally catch the thermal.
The whole thing,
is relatively simple out in the flatlands,
also good for practising.
It gets harder when we
head into the mountains,
toward a mountain with a steep face.
There the thermal is very crisp,
releases very quickly.
That means it's not broad,
but small in area, and accordingly
rather turbulent.
That's good if you want to circle very tightly
very quickly and climb,
but for a beginner it can very quickly
lead to being overwhelmed.
So that you sit nice and loose,
that you work a lot with weight shift.
You core the thermal
nicely on one hand,
but also work really hard with weight.
Many pilots do that far too little,
then work a lot on the brake
and too little with weight shift.
A really important point.
It's also important to leave the thermal,
the updraft,
only when you're sure you'll reach the next point,
the one you'd chosen beforehand.
as well.
And that you don't leave too early
and then don't reach the next mountain at all,
out in the flatland where you expect the next thermal.
Instead, it's really important
that you core the thermal out.
And it takes a lot of patience,
to get the altitude you need,
so that you safely arrive at the next planned point,
where you assume
that the next thermal will happen again,
to take you up again.
The whole thing naturally takes a lot of experience
and at the start, be happy
when you can circle a thermal in the flatland once,
have a nice, comfortable climb,
you can enjoy that.
The success comes with experience.
In thermal flying we also
come at some point to situations
that we might not necessarily want,
namely that our wing then flies
in a way we're not used to.
Asymmetric collapses belong to that,
frontal collapses might belong to that.
What we'll cover in this topic
now,
sorry,
what we'll cover, are the flight manoeuvres.
If you go to the Swiss Hang Gliding Association's
homepage,
you also have the exam manoeuvres,
relevant manoeuvres,
wonderfully explained as video,
because at the exam too
you have to be able to fly certain manoeuvres
of these.
We start with little-ears,
which we already heard about earlier in the landing.
Little-ears is nothing other than
the outermost A-lines of every wing,
it's the outermost A-line,
not to be confused with the stabilo line.
The stabilo line is the one
that attaches to the outermost tip of the paraglider,
is separated and very thin.
But we have the outermost A-line,
which we also use to pull the wing up,
on some paraglider models that's
separated, sometimes together,
it's just always the outermost.
We reach up left and right,
and then fold in our little-ears.
We hold them down and can still steer the wing
with weight shift
just fine.
Little-ears are, as I said,
e.g. when we have a high landing
and need to come down a bit faster,
a great manoeuvre.
Then we can also generate a bit more sink,
to get to know the wing,
by pulling little-ears.
It's an absolutely good manoeuvre.
There are also big-ears,
where, depending on the wing model,
you don't only take the outermost A-line,
but also the second-outermost,
if we have three.
Then much more ear comes in.
Very important there:
there are also wings that only have two A-attachments,
there we mustn't take both in,
otherwise we'll immediately get a frontal collapse.
Then all we do
is grab the ears
and for big-ears
we simply take our hand from the inside
and then bend down.
This way we pull down about 15-20 cm more line
and pull them in for big-ears.
Very important with big-ears,
simultaneously with this process
of pulling in the line:
accelerate.
Only that way can we prevent
ending up with too much ear,
too much drag and the wing flying too slowly,
and then heading toward parachutal stall.
By accelerating, by pushing,
we pull the leading edge here in front back down
and the wing flies again
at the normal angle,
despite the big drag
that the ears create.
Then, to open the ears,
simply let go, and only when the ears
are fully open,
then come off the accelerator.
If we still had the ears in,
let them go and immediately come off the accelerator,
then we still have a lot of drag
and the wing flies slowly,
and when we come off the accelerator,
we might
immediately drift toward parachutal stall tendency,
and we want to prevent that.
Parachutal stall is nothing other than
us flying too slowly.
Our wing should fly, should have forward speed,
now we've fallen below that.
Then, before it essentially
tips backward and fully
empties the air from the wing,
there's a pre-stage of parachutal stall.
The wing is still filled,
but we no longer have forward speed
and we only have sink
and it feels strange.
The wing is mushy up there.
Then we've flown too slowly,
have the brake too far down.
Or flown with a very wet wing.
It can also be that one
ends up in a parachutal stall.
Then it's basically important,
we've flown too slowly.
What's the opposite of slow?
Fast, so we need to get fast.
That means: immediately hands on the A-risers
and push, so you get speed.
Or also accelerate,
as the word shows.
When we hit the accelerator,
we get the wing back into the normal position.
So that it picks up speed again
and we get out of parachutal stall.
What also goes hand in hand with thermal flying
is that we're flying
and we hit a wind shear
and BANG, the wing is 50% in.
Completely out of nowhere.
We get startled first,
which is normal at the beginning,
but here too it's important
that we can react and have to react.
If we do nothing,
the wing creates extreme drag after collapsing.
We still have a slope here,
and things can go bad relatively quickly.
That's why it's important
that we react immediately.
Whether the collapse is on the inside or outside doesn't matter.
When the collapse happens,
our principle must be:
weight to the opposite side immediately,
slight brake with the counter-brake,
if needed,
so that we can fly straight ahead.
Here the principle applies again:
first stabilise, then react.
Then we can deal with the collapse
and reopen it.
If we want to do a rapid descent,
i.e. come down somewhat faster,
because, for example,
we have a thunderstorm approaching
and we say,
we don't want to be in the air much longer,
before the thunderstorm reaches us,
then it can make sense
to master certain rapid-descent manoeuvres.
The big-ears,
which we discussed earlier,
is a really important and good descent manoeuvre,
because with big-ears
you can still steer with weight
and if we're in a strong band of lift,
we fly away from this band of lift
and don't stay inside it.
The B-stall, which is also described here
and asked about at the brevet exam,
has the big disadvantage
that we can indeed do it
and generate quite a lot of sink,
but we come down on the spot,
meaning, if we're in the band of lift,
in the strong one, we're still inside it
and what we actually want is to fly away.
B-stall is nothing other than,
as the name says,
going to the B-risers,
pulling the B-risers slowly down to us.
Important here is
that we have the brakes normally in our hands,
not wrapped or anything,
so that we don't pull them down at the same time,
but that we pull the B-risers down like this.
And then a fold appears in the lower surface here
and I notice
they only have sink
and you can hold it for a few seconds
during a training
or also under supervision
of the instructor on the radio,
you can practise that well.
Releasing the B-stall is nothing other than
guiding the initial part slowly
and then all the way up,
and here, again, for certain
flying patterns,
it's not really a parachutal stall tendency,
if anything, push the B-risers forward,
so it flies faster again.
A spiral dive is a topic of its own.
It's something
you should mainly learn under supervision
or at a SIV course.
But I'll touch on it very quickly.
Spiral dive is nothing other than
a brake,
a relatively firmly pulled weight
fully to the side,
the wing goes into a turn,
gets faster and faster and faster
and starts almost screwing itself out of the sky.
The whole thing happens fairly quickly
and also takes training
to exit cleanly.
That's why you should only learn it under guidance
and be aware
that G-forces,
i.e. the forces acting on you,
increase very quickly,
more than you're used to.
Suppose our weight is 100 kilos.
Now we go into a strong spiral dive.
Could it go up to 4G?
Then 400 kilos are acting on our body.
And not everyone can tolerate that.
That's why it's important
to do proper training
at a safety course under supervision.
Or there's also the option
of the G-Force Trainer,
where you can wonderfully practise on a simulator
and get to know
how you react during spiral-dive stuff.
A new manoeuvre,
which isn't going to come up in the theory question,
but to mention it quickly,
is doing a spiral dive
with a collapse held in.
First you make an asymmetric collapse,
which we've already discussed,
and then on the opposite side,
the one that's open, you do a spiral.
That has the advantage
that you generate a lot of sink,
but have low G-forces.
It's always those G-forces
that can pose a danger.
That's also a manoeuvre,
that belongs to a sequel,
with a twist, wing-over and pitching.
You have to know what those are.
A spin is nothing other than
us pulling one side down too much,
e.g. we wanted to enter a spiral
to land,
but did it completely with gross-motor input
and then one side goes away
and the wing turns negatively.
That's a spin.
If we do that very quickly,
it can be that the wing turns up there
and we down here have a momentum,
where we follow the wing
too slowly.
We're still
in this position from the start.
Then you can imagine,
here are our risers,
very quickly the wing pulls back a bit
and now I have a twist.
That means nothing other than
the risers are crossed.
Then I'm in a twist.
That's the term for it.
If I want to fly a wing-over,
it's nothing other than
bringing the wing into a roll.
That means, I decide
on one side, left or right,
and as soon as I come back down inside,
I'm already giving the opposite side
the brake input and the weight.
Whoosh!
Always weight before brake input.
And then there are so-called wing-overs.
That's a fun manoeuvre
that we also have to
show on the practical exam.
It can happen that it comes up.
There they'll see
that you get the wing-overs to stabilo height
each time.
That means rolling.
That's nothing other than wing-overs.
And it's fun.
It's a good manoeuvre
to get to know the wing and train.
Same with pitching.
Pitching is nothing other than
braking the wing hard.
The wing goes back.
We as the person go forward.
And now we wait
until the wing comes forward again
and shoots forward.
Wait until we swing through underneath.
Now we want to brake again.
We really have to wait
until we're past the lowest point
and then brake again,
so we get a pitching motion.
There too they'll see on the exam
that you pitch to the trailing edge
and leading edge.
It's not an insanely strong pitch,
but we have to manage it on the wing.
That's the goal,
that we get to know the whole thing.
Now the spin-twist manoeuvre
like wing-over and pitching.
All that can be a lot of fun
and makes absolute sense.
For training.
Now it can also be
that the whole thing goes pear-shaped.
And then the topic
of the reserve parachute
comes into play in the next chapter.
You have to be aware,
your reserve parachute
is no use.
It's absolutely useless,
your reserve parachute.
If you don't pull it.
That's a really important principle.
Skydivers have a system
where if they've passed a certain altitude,
the system automatically
deploys the reserve.
We paragliders don't have that.
And due to the design, nobody has yet
managed to find a solution for it.
That means, in an emergency situation
we as pilots actively have to
pull the reserve.
And only when we pull it
does it actually work.
We have to be very firmly aware of that.
If we have a situation,
out of control,
this situation isn't going to improve.
It only improves
when we say,
now it's no longer good,
now I'm out of control,
now I have to pull my reserve.
When I pull it,
the principle is always:
when it's uncontrollable.
Meaning, I have a state
where I no longer know
where up and down are.
And this state doesn't stabilise
within the shortened time,
we're talking 2-3 seconds,
that's time for the reserve.
If I have little altitude in the whole thing,
meaning, I was at the altitude-loss area in the landing zone
and I have low altitude anyway
and I have a problem,
pull the reserve immediately.
Out of control,
I no longer know what the wing is doing,
pull the reserve immediately.
It can happen from a collapse,
it can happen that you've braked too hard,
as we saw earlier,
a spin happens, something uncontrolled,
straight to the reserve.
It can also be that
we have quite a lot of space in the air,
but other airspace users
and if we have a collision,
then it's definitely also time
to pull the reserve.
Because we know ourselves,
if we've had the collision
and are flying again,
we don't know,
is our aircraft so badly damaged
that maybe only then will we notice,
when we're on landing approach,
meaning we can no longer react
and pull the reserve.
It can also happen
that you fly over a big field,
pull the reserve,
if you're already out of control anyway,
the first principle comes back,
the principle to keep in mind,
and pull the reserve immediately.
It can also be
that you have a medical problem,
you launch and things go black before your eyes,
something wasn't okay,
then the reserve is the best option,
flying somewhere unconscious into the terrain
with the paraglider is no good option.
What happens very rarely these days,
or essentially no longer happens,
is material failure,
but it could still happen
that it does after all.
You notice something on the harness
is no longer as it should be
and you have a flight path because of that
that you can hardly hold,
because you're sitting crooked in the harness,
because something has torn,
then it's definitely also a case for the reserve.
The principle of the second chance,
whenever it's uncontrolled,
that the reserve is useful,
is really, really important for all of flying.
I say second chance deliberately,
when we have it
and have to know
how the whole system works.
How that works,
you absolutely have to ask
at your flight school.
You have to train it in the harness,
so you know where the reserve handle is.
A good exercise for that is also,
if you fly out on a normal flight,
with a flat hand,
on every flight,
where the reserve is,
so that in an emergency you'll also know
how to react.
The reserve is a large topic,
there are more things that belong to it,
like how much you have to pack.
Like, for example, manufacturers saying:
repack fresh every six months.
Practice shows a bit
of six months to one year.
Anything else, you really shouldn't do,
packed for longer than a year,
but it needs to be re-folded.
That's a big topic
and a course
in its own right.
What we've discussed here,
the flight practice,
that's what's
asked about on the exam.
You have to know it.
I hope you enjoyed this lecture.
I want to thank you very much
for your attention
and see you soon in the air.